well the big issue which which doesn't
actually get the focus on that requires
our issues approval properly on the
developing world I mean there are still
babies dying of diarrhea and even in the
length of time that it takes us to do
this interview you know maybe 10,000
babies will have died from curable
diseases so you know the news media has
been dumbed down in many ways and digs
with celebrity and ferdi trivia or
superficial the matters or maybe because
it's it's a burr which needs to be fed
it's there's so much media you know it
deals with PEG atrocities or or conflict
situations but beneath all of that
beneath all of that are issues which i
firmly believe her people new people new
mean a child dying of diarrhea can be
cured for two cents two cents a small
satchel of salt and sugar will stop a
child from dying from diarrhea people
knew that they would do something about
it
Oh